The Joe Rogan Experience we're all
occupied with Russia and Ukraine right
now but China's the bigger issue right
in the long term and and we just need
that we need to be able to multitask and
yeah we got to worry about Russia
Ukraine conflict and does that get out
of control or just you know you know
where is it going I guess that's a
bigger question where do you think it's
going
yeah
um I don't think anybody's got a plan in
Washington right now uh or NATO I don't
think anybody knows I think they're all
being basically reactive as opposed to
you know what what's the end game here
what is what is the the final way that
we wrap this up and I mean look we've
spent the U.S has spent
I don't know as of the end of 2022 and
that was that's almost a full year
because it started in February
so almost in a full year the U.S spent
about 50 billion dollars in assistance
and about half of that is military aid
right in a variety of forms right the
high more systems all the way to
protective body armor right so it's it's
all over the map in training
um
if you compare that 50 billion dollars
in Aid to
and so what's that about 25 billion
dollars in military aid if you compare
that to previous year or the year before
we were probably spending on the Ukraine
we were probably spending 250
270 million dollars
in military assistance that's it right
so that ramp up is incredible and then
that doesn't include what the eu's put
into it what the UK has put into it and
everything else so how do you back out
of that right how do you say okay we're
now we're putting a patriot missile
battery in there
um and
you know France and and we have agreed I
think we're looking towards you know
more advanced uh armored technology
we're going to give them tanks that
they've been hankering for hankering
I said hankering
um and so that might be a Ukrainian word
uh
I I don't know when you I don't I have
no idea where it's going to wrap up
Putin's not going to give up Crimea so
what does that mean well you got to
create some Middle Ground then where
it's not going to be a complete victory
for the Ukraine and that's going to make
a lot of people unhappy who are just
standing around waving Ukraine Flags
right and
so where do you go from there I I don't
know you know hopefully there's some
serious negotiations happening off the
radar screen but there doesn't seem to
be a lot of evidence to that effect and
Putin doesn't seem to show any interest
in it
um and he's been able to so far to Tamp
down on the dissidents at home
and really much like with China the only
thing Putin would really fear is losing
power and he loses power if he loses the
population and so far that really hasn't
happened there's been protests
uh people unhappy with the uh sorry that
was mine that's your phone that was my
sports and their alert I guess
yeah exactly whenever there's something
big happening in the World of Sports
um and uh so anyway I I to answer your
question in a very lengthy rambling way
uh who knows where it goes but it would
be nice if we had more open discussion
about it at least in Washington and and
open with our NATO allies about
what's going to happen we can't keep up
I don't think this same pace of support
you know it's it seems unreasonable to
think that we can but
has there been any discussion as to like
how long we do this for
uh not really I think there's uh I think
there's uh
there's a general sense because
everybody's got add there's a general
sense of fatigue to some degree in some
circles but uh saying you want to know
where it's going isn't saying that
you're in support of Putin and that's
part of the problem in today's world if
you say well so where is this all going
people say well [ __ ] you right Putin
puppet well no [ __ ] you I just want to
know what's happening so yeah it's weird
like that isn't it I mean it's it's so
strange that you're either with them or
against them and you can't just be going
what are we doing what is it not working
lift the top go over the top
[ __ ] do you not know how to work a
cigar lighter uh it's hard to teach you
that in the CIA it's technical nowadays
look at that it's not really it's really
[ __ ] easy okay I look like a [ __ ]
monkey [ __ ] a football here with your
lighter do you know how to do it no no
no off the top
I'm trying to lift the top but it's like
give me that [ __ ] oh no I'm gonna
figure this out you're not gonna I'm
gonna spend the next two hours trying to
figure this I think you're on the wrong
side flip it over oh for [ __ ] sake
Jesus Christ there you go look at that
I'm trying to open the bottom calibri
I'm not paying any attention I'm not
paying attention and besides the fact I
use a Zippo oh remember the Zippos or
the ones that leave that nice smell yes
I guess gasoline smell and I got a
couple of Bic lighters too and you know
the nice thing about them I don't have
to [ __ ] with the top that's true right
but anyway that that was uh there you go
that was mildly embarrassing but I'm too
old to be embarrassed about anything
anymore
so I mean worst case scenario is this
breaks out in a nuclear war the top
lifts up
um
that's the worst case scenario right
yeah if you look at if you I mean maybe
this is a good time to say okay 2023
here we are
what should we pay attention to what are
we going to look at with Russia Ukraine
you're right if if suddenly Russia
decides
I'm going with an unconventional weapon
right it's time it's time to break out
you know the nuke
um and let's see what let's see what
that does to the community of of Nations
um so there's that potential in terms of
how to just escalate something happens
in terms of NATO when it drags NATO into
it that's a way this thing escalates
um a cyber security attack in the region
maybe maybe initially targeted at uh at
Ukraine but then it somehow it you know
goes off into uh into NATO allies
creates a major issue shuts down Power
Systems in Poland and surrounding region
so there's ways that this thing could
could uh
escalate get a little bit out of control
maybe as we talked about maybe there's
increasing protest movement in Russia
maybe and that threatens Putin's regime
and that makes him decide to do
something a little bit more drastic what
is the the general consensus from the
Russian people do they they have a
lockdown on the media in Russia right
and even on the internet right yeah they
do they've got um and they've done
they've been very successful and you
know it's not like the old days and
during the Cold War you know you could
put a complete blanket over it right and
and that was it there was no way for
them to get news
they're not completely shut off right so
that's they they know what the hell's
going on Russian people are you know the
population in general you know they're
very
switched on pragmatic they suffer well
and what that's part of the problem they
suffer well but my friends from Russia
have always told me that nobody believes
the media that you know is kind of like
a nod and a wink as to what what the the
media tells you and the people kind of
know that they [ __ ] you right
there's a much more open the the
reaction to the media is much more open
and in the United States like if you're
one of those people that listens to
MSNBC you're all in you know you're all
in with Rachel Maddow she's gone now
right whoever the [ __ ] is over there now
you're all in with those people if
you're on Fox News you're all in with
those people right right uh now the
Russian general populations always had
kind of a dry very sarcastic sense of
humor towards information in general
right what they're being told by the
authorities and that includes the media
so
you know he can't control the population
the way they used to but they still you
know it's still a dictatorship and so
he's still got a significant State
control and the state media is still
very good as is the security apparatus
at controlling the message so they're
very good at that right and so that's
kind of balanced against and they're
they're constantly in this this battle
against you know increasing technology
and its ability to spread information
that's outside the bubble
and so yeah I mean there's there's
dissent there's a feeling of
dissatisfaction but
you know Putin's been he's been very
good in the past at finding the bogeyman
right whenever he's threatened of
pointing to some outside force you know
usually us
um and saying look what they're doing to
us and kind of rallying the troops
getting everyone to to yeah you know the
motherland so
you know I wouldn't it's like hoping
that uh the the moolis is like hoping
the Iranian regime topples under the
weight of this current protest I
wouldn't you know hold on a lot of hope
I wouldn't put a lot of money on it